[Music]
okay hello everyone I'm woman's my
master subpoena for sure and we're here
at the San Luis chess club for today's
lesson we're going to look at the
viewers choice so I have a couple of
games that I prepared for today so we
will try to look at some of the games
that were submitted and try to learn
from them and also you know lucky people
got the chance to see their game so if
you're interested in this be sure to
submit your games to the San Louis chess
club and you can have your games picked
and analyzed so let's get started with
the first game that I have so this game
was sent by Blake and justice for a
second and it's a pretty interesting
game I think a lot of you might might
enjoy it for part of the game it was
played pretty well and white got a
really nice advantage in the groennfell
but then well things changed so I'm
going to put it on training and we'll
get started so we have the groom felled
d5 it's I have an actually really
interesting story about this some of you
might know the San Luis rapid and blitz
took place last week and I was in the
room in the commentary room with var and
Robert Hess and they were discussing
what Kasparov will play in the game
against he Clara Nakamura so he Clara
had white and you know they played t49
f/64 g6 and everybody thought okay we
are going to have the Kings Indian and I
actually guessed somehow there would be
the groom felt nobody was really happy
but it was it was pretty fun so for some
of you who might want to relieve that
you can you can go back and see the
video but I always groom felt is a
pretty popular
opening and there are a lot of there are
a lot of lines that white can choose
here ephors of course pretty popular one
Bishop d2 is something they can be
played as well some people even don't
take in d5 they like to play Bishop g5
in this position or Knight f3 or e3
there are a lot of lines for white so
anyways in this game black played efore
and here Knight b6 and I wasn't to be
surprised to see this this move and if
we look at the rating of the two players
they're both around 1600 on D chess
which I believe lit just kinda has the
the ratings a little bit pumped up so
maybe the players are around 12 1300 I
wouldn't know very much about this but
some of you who use the website might
know typically Knight takes c3 is the
main line yeah we all know this okay so
Knight b6 and what do you guys think
about this move let's also you know hear
some opinions do you think this is a
good move yes
yeah it's it's pretty so the idea of the
groom Feld is basically that the fact
that black is going to develop a little
bit fast the bishop in g7 usually it's a
really strong piece and black typically
plays c5 and breaks through the center
so at first we give away the center it
seems like with the capture and c3 we're
helping white to strengthen the center
but black Cana gets to develop a little
bit faster and this Bishop is typically
a beast so for those of you who play the
groom felt you should be familiar with
some of these ideas and for white when
you're playing these lines you typically
want to find a way to get this rook from
a1 away from from the Square from the
diagonal but also you have to be very
cautious about the d4 pawn sometimes
black tries to make you push it in to
push to push the move d5 and it
typically gets gets crazy so anyway so
Knight b6 doesn't make so much sense for
black because you're you're really just
moving the knight a little bit too much
and you gave white the center and you're
not even trying to have a little bit of
advantage in development but it's not a
super bad move it's not like Black has
lost or anything so why decided to be
really aggressive by playing a four in
this position what do you guys think was
this a good good choice would you play a
four here or is there maybe another move
that you would have considered playing
if you know if there are any d4 players
Bishop d3 so you're trying to kind of
trick him to capture your pawn right -
to do a discovery well typically you
don't place the bishop there typically
you're waiting all the way with this
Bishop this Bishop typically gets
developed in e2 or b5 for white they
don't typically put it in d3 in the
ground field you can certainly try but
okay of course black will not capture
probably play Bishop g7 and then what is
your plan how are you going to finish
your development and what is your actual
plan yes
certainly there are ideas like this to
develop the night you need to a lot of
people get scared to develop their night
enough dream the groom felt but actually
it's not that bad a big of a deal really
even if Bishop g4 is being played you
don't mind the doubling of the pawns
because it is very hard for black to
bring pieces to attack your king so a
lot of people actually develop it in f3
but of course if you have the option and
you want to you can certainly develop it
in e2 as well
I particularly would probably try to
play something like not f3 in this
position maybe Bishop e3 Bishop e2
castle and then place my rook on the C
file just you know they strengthen my
center basically but f4 doesn't seem
that bad of a of an option you know
because with white you have the the
ability to get a little bit more more
space so why not do it I think this was
a good one okay you know move Bishop g7
Knight of three c6 now I want to ask you
what do you guys think about this move
c6 like it for black not so much not so
much huh yes it's it's a little bit
strange I mean that's typically a place
for the night black typically placed
with c5 puts pressure in d4 and then
develops a knight there so sistex is a
little bit of like a solid type of move
and it kind of restricts black you know
and they don't try to get very much from
the position so here we have a pretty
good play from white finishing the
development Bishop e6 mm-hmm not the
place to be for the bishop right g4 is
slightly better Square for that bishop
but okay castle castle and in this
position white played Bishop e3 which
not only I would like but in this
position with Bishop e6 black has some
ideas right it's controlling the c-4
square and could place either the bishop
or the knight in CL
so when you see a piece like
that doesn't seem to be on the best
place but does have some idea so it's
not really like a bad choice you really
want to restrict them and especially
because this is why it has so much space
with these central pawns I would really
I would have gone for a b3 this is a
very nice in a way prophylactic move but
also could help your development you
could consider develop the bishop in b2
as well but what I like the most is the
fact that the pawn restricts this 19 b6
and not only that in this case also the
bishop
so black wouldn't have any kind of
activity here and just has to ask
himself what is he going to do next
because white has you know white has
basically control up to 5th rank and and
blacks simply restricted right so when
you get the center it is very very
important to try to restrict the
opponent even more and not let them the
chance to counter-attack because
eventually they will realize okay I have
known space I need to do something so
you really don't want to let them do
anything and you want to restrict them
as much as possible and something else
that you don't want to do which later
you will see why did is straight pieces
if your opponent doesn't have space you
don't want to help them if you trade
their pieces they will start having you
know the space to maneuver the rest of
their pieces right so if you let them
there how are what what is this not
going to do what is this one from b8
going to do right it's just it's just
very very restricted for black and then
you know once you finish your
development so let's just say something
like this you can always play king h1
just to make sure nothing will happen in
your opponent d4 Queen d2 I would i
would say rook d1 and then you can
consider starting your attack but why
play Bishop e3 and now what choice did
it allow black to do
94 but no it hasn't be played Bishop c4
is play so which of the two do you think
is better do you like Bishop c4 do you
like 9 c4 more nice you four okay so
let's try to think of how would have
white continued here
where do we move the bishop or you we
take it what did you say yes so you want
and can black capture this pawn Oh Queen
b3 be careful there's a wish
can I get the you cannot get the night
immediately you would have to move your
queen and then I think I can come back
to see for so and if you take then you
give the bishop air at least black get
something out of this space last
position but okay Blanc decided to go
Bishop c4 which also makes make some
sense trading a piece and you have no
choice but to allow the trade and in
this position white played rook to c1 I
think Bishop takes c4 was another option
and here bishop f2 because now if black
captures will be a mistake because now
we have this move Queen to e2 and
controlling of course everything is
controlled so this night is going to be
lost so at least if you make the trade
just I think you can make sure that that
that night would be chased away so for
example after 97 now Queenie - chasing
the night away and then yes we did trade
one piece but that's it and then the
night from Sephora will be chased away
back and we still have a very big
advantage with white yes yes
well fifth it will be 5th right because
yeah f65 be 64 and out back so and 5
moves out of 4 13 is pretty bad it's
very bad for a piece I mean there are
some openings where it's fine like the
Alec kind defense for example but you
really need to you really need to have
some counter-attack you can not play
without doing something in the center so
anyways I think this this was a slightly
better option for white instead white
play look to see 197 and I believe once
again this this is this is possible
white could have taken you see for
played Bishop f2 Queen e2 you know in
case of the capture and things would be
fine but instead white played Knight e5
and I did just mention that this move is
a dubious move but I'm tempted to say
that it's a bad move why do why do you
think that I'm saying this about the
move Knight e5
trading guys I mentioned trading we have
more space
look at this 19 f3 right it's already by
comparing this Knight to this one we can
see that this knight in f3 I should make
it green because it's it's a better
night it's a little bit better place
than this one in d7 and and we don't
want to trade pieces not only this after
Knight e5 white basically says well once
you trade
I don't mind doubling my pawns which if
you would have some continuation or you
would be able to use the F file to your
benefit maybe it would be a great thing
right you you would be able to create
some attack and things would would work
in your favor but the problem is after
95 capture F takes the position is not
so great for white anymore it's I'm
having trouble figuring out how white is
going to create some some some serious
threats ideas with ecigs
typically are famous for for these types
of position to get rid of the double
pawn and maybe try to create some
weaknesses but right now it doesn't it
doesn't quite work there's a bit sharpen
and we just closed this bishop in g7 so
we we did another pretty good thing but
the the balance it doesn't add up in my
opinion in for the balance so it's we're
trading black's pieces who don't have
space and and we're not really getting
very much out of it aside from the fact
that we're closing the bishop in g7
really the F file it looks great but in
my opinion cannot really be used by
white for for having a great advantage
black played e6 here B 340 which are I
think it's okay for black
you would want but you can still do it
even after you play six because if you
play f6 at some point the trade and you
can later play if I think the reason
black played east six was you know if
the trade was going to happen so there
white wouldn't have u6 so considering
that you want to trade a bishop it makes
sense to to kind of locate the position
in my opinion plus the fact that these
pawns are creating a chain with the pawn
in d4 so typically right in the ground
felt the move would have been Knight
takes c3 so why would have had the chain
kind of more back so it would be hard
for black to actually attack it but here
because this is the base of this chain
right I can play c5 as well and that's
how the the dark square Bishop is going
to be opened so I think I think e six
was wasn't a right move if white would
have had two knights to somehow get to
f6 hmm I wouldn't say the exact same
things but considering the situation and
the fact that this Knight cannot really
get to f6 so easily I think the move is
okay
b3 we offered the trade and now Queen h4
so black is finishing the development is
finished okay move 15 and what could be
blacks plan now
prepared to play c5
yeah some of the eight and it's very
interesting Queen h4 is also somewhat of
an attraction type of move because it
says well I don't really have any
threats on the kingside but feel free to
play rook a foreign and double and
Raqqah four is actually not really
helping white very much because their
plan is not on the F file there's
something very important to realize you
will see there will be positions where
your opponent will have what it looks
like a backwards pawn and you'll think
oh I have to focus on that but the way I
like to explain it is if you see a pawn
that's backwards just make sure you have
sufficient pieces to attack it and I say
sufficient I also refer to the idea that
you should have more pieces than the
opponent so you should have more pieces
that are tagged that weakness then they
have to protect it otherwise it's just
going to be like a waste of time and why
should actually focus on the Queen side
in my opinion because now with the
position closed on the Kings side you
have you can try to create like a
minority type of attack but also you can
utilize the fact that this night doesn't
have squares and this is a very famous
idea for groennfell style positions a4
of course we do to play a five chase the
night away and then you can also either
utilize those two squares if black will
play a six or you can try to play before
b5 and and create some weakness and open
up your C file
so this is in my opinion the plan that I
should have taken instead Ruka forest
played the Queen retreated to e7 which
was probably the square where the Queen
could have gotten immediately to Luke f1
once again attacking something that's
super well defended and now cream before
of course
as we mentioned earlier c5 whenever in
the plan for black really attacking the
base of this chain of ponds and working
on finally opening up that Bishop which
is the strength in the crown fold but ok
black played Queen before and white made
a small mistake here Queen c3 why is
this a smaller better said big mistake
what's happening simple night right
simple night blunder and ok it's it was
pretty ok game balanced so far with you
know a little bit more advantage for
white then it was balanced but this is
certainly a big mistake and typically
when I teach my my private students I
always stop after these things like this
I just think okay there's no point to
keep going but of course depending on
the level you have a lot of things to
learn and you can use a lot of tactical
ideas so of course the 90s attacked you
have to move it and and try why I'm
saying to d1 and not d1 while I'm trying
to kind of bring the knight towards a
nice square if you really want to try to
attack you can try to bring it that way
but of course c5 is is blacks plan so
that's that's what they should do is
black well--why blundered and what do
you guys think did black take the knight
or no of course of course
so white took Luke f7 so they had an
idea you know I'm I like to see when
people are creative so he he probably
thought that if he plays Queen f3 black
would not be able to capture the pawn in
c3 because your takes f7 but there's no
need to panic okay does white have any
threats in this position after rook
takes f7 rook takes rook rook takes rook
there's another threat white actually
has a threat in this position but it is
not rook takes rook
it's rook takes g7 right because we have
a small tactical idea here a discovery
so we want to take in g7 if the King
takes Bishop h6 check and then taking
the Queen and yeah okay so how can we
stop that threat all right can you what
candidate moves do we have here with
black
take the rook and now add any ideas that
white could could have to continue the
attack or not so much
probably not too much but but you can
also play like the movie ended here King
h8 you cannot capture my bishop because
your paint right and well you can take
there if you want but that will be there
will be all of it you don't have a
discovery and I have an extra piece it
is very important to look to not to
panic when the opponent attacks you just
look for the threads and try to find
ways to defend it's it's not you know
it's not so serious unfortunately in
this position black didn't realize what
was White's threat and thought me I it's
very surprising but what to do that
point in b7 is being attacked but why
doesn't actually threaten to take it
right it's just it's very interesting of
course it depends on the level of the
people but you know a threat is not
necessarily something that's being
attacked you have to to make sure threat
is something that you want to do the
next move that would be good for you
so just because the pieces is under
attack it doesn't mean that is actually
threatened and here that pawn and b7 is
not threatened but unfortunately for
black he made this or she made this move
rook to b8 and of course rook to e7
King takes g7 and now Bishop h6 and the
game you know finished here but black
had one more choice here not not to lose
the game and that choice was to play
King to h8 and I found the best for
right that I can do is probably some
perpetual check but I didn't I was
unable to find a way through which white
can win because while your queen is
attacked and the rook is unplaced so you
basically you need to do something about
these two pieces
you cannot play a move like rook after
seven why
yeah not directly right you probably
take your first right yeah just take
here quintics and then you can take the
bishop just need to make sure you come
back and protect your king and anyways
but white can have some perpetual ideas
with rook takes h7 check and then grab
some material but there's no more than
perpetual check I didn't find more than
that so where is it well to see I think
it was an interesting game right there
there's some some cool stuff to learn
regarding the the positions at the
beginning was a positional chess and
then it went more tactical but the main
thing to remember is when you have the
space do not trade pieces I think that's
that's a big thing okay questions about
this game yeah it was a blitz game yeah
so okay it was a pretty pretty fast game
so okay so let's see one more game
another one that was pretty interesting
and I was sent by my name and I'll put
it on training I have my my own
discussion but also he has added some
discussion here himself okay so and this
was by the way a game played as you can
see between a father and and his son so
anyways it's it's cool to see is it cool
to see the games like this it was over
the board so I believe it was like just
a normal game they had enough time to
think about but we don't know their
ratings so well we'll try to figure out
okay so d45 have you guys ever
encountered this yes okay so it's about
what level is this is this played a lot
one minute oh wow okay well I think I
think you can play I've seen some
players you know yeah but not one minute
really
I guess one minute it would make sense I
remember when I go but back to playing
bulla - to consider this of course the
budapest gambit makes a little bit more
sense but this one okay and I don't know
but white chose not to take it which
which makes sense if you're if you're if
you think you are allowing your opponent
to develop the pieces too fast then you
might not want to to take the pawn and
you might want to go for the space I
don't see anything wrong with that
of course capture is another option then
probably knight c6 Knight f3 and I think
this is a better position than the
budapest gambit but I've seen people
playing f6 here or or d6 and they do get
some play so it's you know there's
nothing wrong with this but d5 you know
if you have some knowledge in in King's
Indian position keeps Kings Indian type
positions then I believe d5 does make
sense and you're trying to get through
your openings but again we don't know
the level of our viewers so we cannot
really tell very much okay so we got
into kind of an old Indian position and
basically here white played 93 but for
any of you who are playing this with
white in my opinion
efore is a better move so the idea is
that in case a capture happens you want
to bring your night out to c3 and you're
going to try to maintain a piece in e4
that outpost is really important in
King's Indian types of positions and in
case black protects it with Knight f6
Bishop f5 your idea is you're going to
bring your knight other night to g3 to
bring more pressure on e4 and then
there's also Bishop g5 this
being played sometimes you give the
bishop for that 19f six other times you
don't need to but you will manage to get
your pawn back so for some of you who
are interested in in or don't have a
system against these types of positions
you can certainly look up this efore
move in this here Knight c3 Knight f6
now of course you can play E for once
again so you'd get similar positions
with the ones that I mentioned if black
doesn't take what you guys think you
will do it white development right so
the bishop can still go to g5 this one
can go to d3 the Knight f3 or d2 it
really depends whether black will try to
push or not but you can if you put a
little bit more pressure on f5 they will
have to do something about that point
but just remember typically you want to
remain with the piece in e4 not upon
anyways here white played Queen to c2
but the problem is not a little bit of a
strange situation because you don't
manage to to protect both d5 and e4 so
it has gotten into a really interesting
position after F takes e4 Knight takes
e4 for example if black would have taken
here Quinn takes Bishop e7 I think black
has has a decent position to play
for example Knight f3 Castle then you
want to pick up a five if white will
take with which piece do you think we'll
take back the night or the pawn you'd go
in the night that both of them I think
are are interesting if you take with a
pawn you will try to have the center if
you take with the night you'll have to
be careful a little bit about the d5
square and the backwards pawn but it
depends it depends whether you will be
able to create some threats place
uniting before or not I think both both
of them are are equally good in this
game well I did a game but we won't see
it till the end but it was played
between oh I didn't I don't write it
never mind but for example let's just
say continuation Bishop d3 Bishop f5
black can simply trade that Bishop and
then we don't have big troubles I think
black equalised without any problems do
you guys agree okay would you prefer to
play white or black in this position
black I would probably take black too
there but anyway so that game didn't
didn't quite go this way black took with
a pawn in d5 what do we do here with
white
very good pawn takes context who is
better in this position
I like whiteness in this position the
only thing you have to be and the look
for is this point d5 to make sure you're
not going to lose it
but of course right now ideas with Queen
a5 capture are not good for black
because they have their bishop hanging
so they cannot look at those for the
moment and black continue their
development with the 19 d7 and it's
always tricky
I've always wondered I used to be a
banana player with black and I still
play it sometimes and sometimes you
develop the knight through d7 other
times through a6 and both have different
ideas but I think in this position
especially because white has this point
in d5 which cannot be protected by
another pawn it would make a little bit
more sense to develop the knight in a
six the idea is that you well you have
two ideas one would be to place the
night there a very typical idea which
you have also with 1987 but if you place
a 1986 you also maintain this other idea
to place your 19 c7 and put pressure on
the pawn in d5 I don't think there's a
big difference between these two moves
but typically just remember that it's
important to to play with more than one
idea when you start playing with more
than one idea your level will increase
as well because you know it well it will
also make it harder for your opponent to
stop both of the ideas but if you just
go for one like threat move after move
after move then your opponent will
probably you know figure it out and you
won't get you won't get very much from
the front positions so I think 96 makes
a little bit more sense here for black
but 97 was played Bishop d2 Knight b6
Bishop e2 can we capture the pawn in d5
we can
is it good we'll find out Bishop h5
check King g7 have you guys ever seen
games where somebody remains with the
King in the center one of your games
great well what do you think about this
King what do you think about blacks King
is blacks King okay there it's a decent
forgers yeah with this pause here I mean
he's doing pretty alright um just needs
to make sure that no other piece will
infiltrate but for the moment black ass
alright but he has to you know maintain
this so white finish their development
92 Bishop e6 seems pretty good for black
right at this point black has an extra
pawn right and if I managed to develop
my pieces I should be fine castle rook
c8 Queen b3 was this good or no we why
just trying to have some little threats
from this side but there's also plays
his Queen on a potential discovery so b6
display black buy black I have a
question for you a move like Knight f4
would a move like Knight f4 word here
for black
it's possible so what do we do with
white
for example oops yeah you can do
something like this and you took a
little pawn but after b6 black can start
considering ideas like this and white
seem not to care and play rook e1
neither for Queen f3 and now Bishop d5
which I don't like very much I think if
you play Knight f4 you should have gone
for the bishop first of all black would
have taken the pair of bishops trading
pieces isn't their favorite they have an
extra pawn right and also not trading
pieces black would be trading an active
piece of whites that's kind of annoying
and restricting the scheme keeping it in
the center so this way we would have
some ideas like I don't know like
Queenie 8 for example try to trade a
queen we need to try to trade pieces and
if let's say obviously if if white takes
the Queen we take with the King and now
what is I mean I think black would have
no trouble we need this position right
the pair of Bishops passed pawn this one
Center to two central pawns c-file the
King is already placed perfectly in the
center for the endgame this you know so
if you're white and you are supposedly
attacking well they're not attacking
very much right now but you have a look
on the same file as the King you have
the Queen kind of act if you don't want
to trade so you play a move like Queen
h4 but after Queen f7 let's say you
bring one more rogue now look g8 and
it's not going to be so clear who is
attacking who in this position because
black can start some attack on the G
file as well and the fact that the king
is not in the center doesn't necessarily
mean the King is weak so like we were
mentioning earlier there is a small
fortress that black has created and it's
not so easy to break it through so in my
opinion black should have just taken
that bishop
and you know white would suffer with the
pond down but in the game Bishop d5 was
played and here our viewer has played a
beautiful move Queen takes f4 and while
I I really wanted to show this game
today as well because it reminded me of
my my US Championship win where I
sacrifice the Queen so I thought it
would be nice to show this game so what
is happening after pawn takes it's not
it's not going a hundred percent in
white favor but they can't they get a
really good advantage how do we continue
here with white check only one move for
black King to d7 how about now
well let's think about it for a second
we have sacrificed a queen for a night
right so night and a pawn so
do we have any other candidate moves
besides we showed you four that's our
only one just to make sure
mr. p8 is another candidate move yeah
which one would we go for
casualization the thing is after Bishop
e8 Queen takes that's the small problem
and you take here if it would be your
move and you could take in f6 then it
would be great but unfortunately it's
not so black has a much much better
position they can just protect this
Bishop g7 or rook somewhere
or maybe they could have even taken with
the king so no Bishop g4 makes sense
very good we don't want to take this
bishop though right because we wouldn't
have sufficient material with white for
the Queen sacrifice I mean yes it's true
this King is in the center but you want
to have sufficient material as well but
you continue things with check Bishop g4
check in c7 and now rook c1 was very
very important to be made by white
because black cannot play Bishop c6
we've got this check right and winning
the Queen which is very important
so if black plays I don't know PBA Tour
King b7 then we take and we'll have a
piece up so here in this line that I had
here Knight b6 check takes the queen
with check and now Bishop c3 this one
cannot be protected because if Bishop g7
with carlucci 7 check and white has a
better big advantage so it went from
from much worse
a pawn down and not the serious attack
to to something you know tactical idea
it's very important for a lot of us to
do tactics because I can have ideas like
this you know sacrifice and then get a
lot of pieces for the Queen and have a
great position actually why didn't make
the best move here
they played Bishop takes the 8th after
King takes now it's not so simple to get
the Queen but ok black made some
mistakes you know it's tough to you know
before coming to San Luis to be a GM
resident I played a tournament and I
played the game where I had a queen for
a rook and I was unable to win so it can
happen to 21 you really need to make the
evaluation of the position and figure
out whether your queen is stronger than
the pieces or are the pieces that the
opponent has stronger than yours here I
think black should have tried something
like look G Aten and simply get the rook
away from the diagonal instead a five
force played and now Bishop c3 very good
played by very well a very good move
played by white knight Knight f6 and
black blundered didn't realize the
threats we had two threats here and
black only looked at one so Bishop g7
had to be played it's kind of tough to
play this position but but Queen versus
two rooks can can be held right we can
have a lot of threats and and especially
because the rooks are not active
if the rooks would have been on the
seventh rank creating some mating
threads yeah but we would worry with
black but here probably the game would
end in a draw but unfortunately black
played rook to g7 unfortunately for them
and after rook e8 the game is over so
two very interesting games that we've
seen so far I think we might have time
to do a little well one more what did
you guys think about these nice games of
our viewers are not so nice interesting
some sacrifice is a little bit of
tactics here and there okay somebody was
really excited about this EP so let's
try to see how much of it we can get get
going okay
so pink to nicholas against somebody we
don't know she didn't tell us the name
of his opponent but we know that his
rating was 1588 and it's a tournament
right it's a tournament game so that's
all we know okay and they're very
excited so we chose their game I mean
his game okay some English that switched
into something else
she takes d4 Knight takes d4 96 anyone
is familiar with this kind of opening
like English I English we got into an
English now yeah so what should white
play in this position
night-night retreat 92 here there 92 or
III don't take the night
don't take the night in sistex you're
probably helping black to improve their
position but 92 or e3 our main lines
here for white well in this game why
play Knight f3 which I don't like
because well why why why play while
returning f3 you're trying to get an
advantage with white this is something
everyone should learn my friends here in
class but those who are watching online
to you know it's important to develop
your pieces and especially when you have
white is important to to maintain some
small advantage for as long as possible
if you go back you don't really get very
much of the from the position right two
pieces two pieces and where's this night
going very why why is 92 a main line
because this night eventually will be
rerouted towards d5 that's something
very important to know because black
needs to get this Bishop out and in
order to take it out this six is going
to be played and if districts is going
to be played a six probably will not be
played also because this pawn in d6 will
remain weak so typically that's an
outposts not outposts forever because it
can the night can be chased away from
there but that's that's the way to go
for white but Knight of three is not is
not such a great alternative Bishop
takes c3 pawn takes c3 Queen a5 black is
still playing the same kind of fashion
as they would play after night c2 Queen
c2 f5
what do you think about this move I see
some faces people are unhappy about this
move but you're not saying much about it
sorry unhappy were very happy about this
move for black you are not happy for
black or for white so it's a good move
for black
yes it's very typical for this type of
opening so I like to use these these
things so as you learn to play chess you
learn some very basic stuff and
fundamentals and everything and then as
you improve all those things it's not
like they don't matter so much but you
start creating even more rules around it
so you're learning that you shouldn't
play the f-pawn at the beginning but but
then as you improve as a chess player
you learn that sometimes most like this
makes sense especially if you are you
have an idea further or we are
restricting your opponent from doing
something and also if you don't weaken
your King or you don't do weaknesses for
yourself very much but you're doing
something good then moves like this are
good so this f5 basically what it's
doing is is helping restrict efore for
white right but also helping black
getting that night at some point to a
stronger place and it's just a really
nice restrictive move and yes
so anyways Bishop g5 h6 a bishop retreat
at Knight f6 very typical and now d6
I don't think I don't like this move so
much I think blacks should go with b6 in
my opinion because what is White's
problem these double pawns White's pawn
structure on the Queen side has been
destroyed so if you look at it on a
balanced black gave away their fee on
keto bishop the bishop there is going to
protect their king for the purpose of
creating weaknesses on the Queen side
and messing up White's pawn structures
so if you do that you need to utilize
what you got because you gave away
something so what you got are those
pawns and you have to find a way to
start attacking them and typically it
will be six Bishop h6 rook c8 start
putting pressure on the
and that's something that black did not
do black lady 6 here 94 of course black
does not want to take in d4 and help
right improve the pawn structure so
Bishop d7 I like him the c5 here because
you also don't want to take in c6 right
this position is much better for black
even if your pawns are not doubled on
the on an open file black's pawn
structure has improved as well and and
the fact that you have the pair of
bishops is not really helpful because
they don't have a good diagonal to
actually do something
so now b3 would would have probably been
played by white and I think after Queen
c7 Black has a great play will have to
bring his King to safety and then start
putting pressure on the weakness okay so
black chose the wrong plan typically
this plan can anybody tell me when is
this plan with a6 b5 happening for black
in a similar bone structure but not here
in which bone structure does anyone know
which one the Mark Martin yes yes that
one yeah it's okay I pronounce it
differently also yes in the marzipan
structure because well typically there
are three pawns here and black doesn't
have so typically that that's how white
place is there pause and they have a
pawn in e4 also of course and black is
really restricted they don't have any
piece that has crossed the six ranks
they really want to get some space as I
was mentioning to you
from the first game that we saw and
black typically does this they sometimes
even give away a pawn just to get some
play but here why would you want to
trade White's doubled pawns you want to
attack them you want to win them so that
was blacks mistake so white took
to job it did very well through b1 Queen
c7 finished the development and now
finally Black is attacking the night the
poignancy for I'm sorry with a night
rook d1 King f7 I
I was very surprised about this move I
don't know I think black should Castle I
mean not kicking yourself here they can
take the pawn no I mean sometimes you do
you do that you play King you have seven
in your oak will be brought into play
but why why there's no necessity you can
also castle it's the same thing and you
actually bring the rook on the f out
that sometimes their ideas with E 5 and
f4 so sometimes not here but King F 7
doesn't make very much sense to me plus
the pawn of thinking so and hopefully
you guys can see that here for example
rook takes b7 is a blunder why
yeah Bishop a4 Bishop a4 yeah yeah
Bishop a4 okay and now
the rookie strap now
not sure a a five first or I felt like
the truck will be lost very soon hmm
a five No
we don't like it something happens is
there something I'm missing
hmm looks okay it looks like that truck
won't be trapped because you cannot move
both pieces and move your knight so if I
take the rook the next move I think
it'll be like Queen c6
from not missing some tactics this is
the way to go that that should not work
okay can I can I put the Queen somewhere
else
I can also
I can also move the Queen here and then
attack it again
and I mean that rook should be lost very
soon I take the rook
if 9500 I didn't see but okay black
didn't taken after king f7 queen bee -
now if you take in c4 I will be able to
take em b7 so black play d5 Knight b3
and Bishop c6 again I'm a little bit
surprised that black would not want to
capture the pawn you know don't put a
night in the mark on the margin and
forget about it
make sure you follow your plans I mean
it's it's really it's really important
so anyways after Bishop c6 here
Queen a3 takes takes h5 you know we look
at this position if we switch like if I
go back with a notation you see this
position but if you earlier had seen C
like this position Y you realize that
white was helped a lot his pawn
structure has improved
you know he's finished the development
and blended finish his development as
well but traded some piece that it
wasn't so helpful to trade a knight in
that in that fashion so anyways let's
try to finish this oops I'm sorry
okay so anyways black started some
attack that you know it doesn't really
work to attack this way you need to be
able to open a file and h5 unfortunately
doesn't help them c5 and d5 c4 I like
this move very much now white is
actually getting a better position
because they're having the pair of
Bishops so when we have the pair of
bishops we want our bishops to have good
diagonals and within the last two moves
white was allowed to you know open up
the position like it's trying to keep it
closed but unfortunately that pawn is
going to be to be lost pretty fast
before it was maybe a better move for
white but okay Bishop a5 rook e1 a
little discoveries on the way now Bishop
f3 the rook is protected so we don't
need to to worry about the sacrificing
me one Queen a4 takes takes f3 who is
better in this position
because
Misha versus night if you don't have a
way to sustain it to help it push is
going to be lost eventually and why just
is not as much better it was slightly
better in this position creepy - Bishop
d2 taking the rogue but it's not it's
not winning and now white made a mistake
Luke takes you one after Bishop takes
anyone probably it's it's not so clear
but after rook takes you one do you know
what black did check check and now Queen
c3 and trade and you have to be a little
bit careful here not to not to lose this
but unfortunately in this position black
blundered 97 so it's really important to
realize in this in this endgame that you
might lose the pawn so you have to find
a way to kind of create to force y to do
something so if you for example here you
push c2 you're threatening to promote
white has to place the bishop in e3 so
the King doesn't arrive to actually come
grab the pawn and now 97 the move order
in which black did the things was was
wrong because now for example before
right because I'm threatening to or just
simply take because of the promotion
your your bishop cannot do anything so
you have to play before and now black
manages to activate the night and will
probably trade these two pawns and the
game would probably end in a draw Bishop
a foreign King here and
okay probably white has some chances to
make a drop but instead here black made
a mistake he went 97 first and now white
has managed to put his king in the box
in the box of that pawn and after F for
white is winning because now I'm taking
this pawn I'm not giving anything away
and I can just win at my own leisure so
pretty pretty nice game kind of went
back and forth and yeah hopefully you
enjoyed these games that's all that I
have from viewers choice so
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]